all right so tonight we got a very very
special edition of chess openings
explained
I'm Jonathan Shantz and today we had a
very special request from Ben Simon so
Ben came to me he said hey can you do
the Von Henning sharra gambit and I said
sure so here we are and we're going to
look at a very aggressive and sharp
opening tonight and it's an opening
where you have a pop on and sometimes
it's not clear what your compensation is
so it is the kind of opening you really
want to study because there's a lot of
venom lying beneath this this opening
and there's a lot of potential for white
to get into trouble really quickly when
black develops a big initiative so we're
going to jump over to the board right
away and the opening begins d4 d5 and
after c4 e6 we have the Queens gambit
declined which is you know a nice slow
positional whites a little bit better
you know you know there's lots of
maneuvering in a long game but there's a
little surprise and this really only
works this gambit if white plays this
exact move order so if you are
interested in in playing the tirage
which is what we're going to be looking
at tonight you do want to have something
in mind if okay if white exchanges on d5
first or plays Knight f3 and it does
limit White's options as well but that's
not the theme of the lecture so we're
going to look at first of all the trash
this is what happens when black plays c5
it's a very aggressive and ambitious
system so very often we're going to end
up with some weaknesses in the center
black often gets an isolated Queens pawn
and what can try to prove that the
center is a liability for black it's
really an ambitious way for black to
play and just to show the main line just
so we can compare it we won't go too
deep into it so normally they take on d5
this is the main move
and typically white plays the Rubinstein
variation we'll just put this on the
board he fee and shadows his Bishop week
and after some moves we get a position
like this so this would be like the
start of the main line for this system
and white hopes to target this deep on
so at any moment he can play D take c5
and he has lots and lots of things
aiming at d5 and the bishop can come to
g5 and remove one of the defenders so
that's what typically happens so when
you play the tirage preps why just
thinking I'm gonna get this position and
you're going to play some very
positional opening and it the trush is a
very interesting one so hopefully we
have time at some point to come back and
have a good look at it but tonight we're
going to focus on a very interesting
gambit so after they take on d5 instead
of recapturing on d5 we're going to take
on d4 and this does involve upon
sacrifice so here's the start of the
gambit this is the Vaughn heading Chara
gambit and there's actually two moves
for white I think the most obvious one
is taking on d4 so we're going to look
at that first but then we'll also talk
about Queen to a4 which is the second
move that white may play just with the
idea of Miss placing the bishop before
taking back the pond so we'll look at
that and talk about some of the
differences but first let's look at what
happens if y it simply takes this is the
most obvious move I think if you this
first time you've ever seen it de pon
singing you just take it now instead of
just taking on d5 right away we have
time to exploit the pin on the D file so
we can get this free developing move in
there so we play Knight to c6 you
obviously can't take and the white queen
wants to stay connected to d5 so
typically they retreat all the way back
to d1 and the idea is after we take here
we can see the black is going to lose
his deep on so what what is this how
does this gambit really work why can you
play this way I can just take it and I
guess I'll ask the audience
if you guys were white in this position
how would you take the pawn with the
knight
okay and the main move is to take with
the Queen but let's have a good look at
this so I'm glad somebody set it so in
this position black already can be
better and it's it comes surprisingly
quickly how he can become better with
the move Knight to f6 okay so I'm
attacking your knight there's maybe some
couple different moves you can consider
but let's just examine what happens if
we trade okay you're up a pawn after
also trading seems to make a lot of
sense but now you'll realize quickly I
do have sort of an annoying threat here
as black my next move is going to be
Bishop to b4 for example if you just
play Knight f3 which might be fine I'm
going to throw this check in and this is
going to be kind of annoying for you
first of all if you play here you are
undefended you're beep on so I can
consider castling or I can simply just
take on b2 I get my pawn back and okay
obviously there's there's lots of
complications here but this should be
very decent for black so there's no
reason for a way to give the pawn back
and if Knight here well you just you
just have a very bad position and in
fact after Bishop to f5 white might
already even be losing here just it's
hard to believe so if you just play a
few moves let's see how does it work
there's something like this in 95 and
line goes something like this and okay
the computer is just like I'm just
winning somehow and it just gives black
monster numbers but it's just even if
you don't see the immediate like
checkmate or whatever you can just kind
of tell that that's not what the knight
wanted to do that wasn't his his dream
job in life was just to go back and okay
some points tonight we're going to mess
around with different things but I
think this one is of particular
importance so we will instead focus on
to move the most humans have played in
this position which is the move a 3 so
this is the typical response that's been
played and now I want to introduce a new
idea now most humans play Bishop to c5
with some threats and it's it's a
tempting move but there's all sorts of
bishop moves that seem very tempting in
this position but I want to show you
guys just a little example of how
quickly things can go wrong for white if
I just played Bishop e7 and I Castle now
white is a long way from castling so how
can we exploit you know our initiative
our leading development here well let's
just put a few moves on so we'll castle
first he'll start to get his pieces out
and after a move like rook to d8 this is
another just pretty developing move
let's get the rook into the action
attack the Queen if the Queen goes the
c2 well c2 or b3 we're going to be able
to wherever it is gained another tempo
on the Queen so let's pretend that they
go somewhere very very safe really far
away I do want to try this very
interesting move in this position and
then I'll test the class and the move is
Bishop to h3 yeah so we've played this
before not this variation but this
Bishop to h3 is a very common motif and
what is the point I mean what's that all
about and I think you'll find it's very
hard to play white in a position like
this I'll ask you guys what you would do
but let's answer first this obvious
question what happens if you take the
bishop now I take here I'm on your hook
if you go here I have a very annoying
move Bishop h4
and okay if you have to play a move like
rook g3 or something well I'm going to
take it and win the exchange and your
King is kind of stranded there so this
is not exactly what you want to do
let's also mention this I suppose you
can have your pick could you want to
mate with a queen or a rook
all right checkmate so that's how fast
things can start to go wrong for white
because obviously he took upon in the
beginning moved as Queen around a bunch
and black olive just pieces out and
castled early but this is an interesting
challenge if you guys were white here
what would you play because I think
you'll start to find it's it's really
hard to move any of your pieces if you
move your bishop here yeah
if you move your bishop you're unde
offending your beep you beep on if you
move this Bishop you're losing your Jeep
on how do you guys handle this is white
because I also want to give you this
idea that so you kind of feel what the
white player would feel in a position
like this they can get really
uncomfortable and just having played
this with a lot of members this week
I've noticed that a lot of people get
really really scared when they're facing
these lines I just know people are like
whoa you know some people even wouldn't
even play me because they're like these
lines are too sharp and scary and I
don't want to do it so that's sort of
the mentality that you can often impose
your will upon your opponent because
you're playing this really sharp
complicated opening and all right
they're like they get kind of nervous
and it's very easy to make mistakes they
puff try to play a little too cautious
or they play inaccurately and they can
get punished right away but I have you
guys come up with a move here as white
and it's hard to even move
rook j1 okay so this is actually a move
that I've looked at already so you
really didn't want to put your rook on
g1 so this is an accomplishment for me
even if I just retreat I don't know I
can go here I can go to e6 and then
later try to control you know some of
the like squares over here but even a
move like this now you're going to find
it very hard to Castle as white so
that's not a move you want it to play so
you're up upon but you know I don't I
don't like the way some of your pieces
are so I don't know how you guys feel
about it but I really prefer black here
and you know and again it's if you have
to make some silly move like that then
it's it's really black that's been
taking control of the position but yeah
you can just already notice it's just
really hard to move white in most of
these lines wants to keep the bishop on
c1 at least until after he's castled
because the defense of this B pond we're
gonna see it more is really important in
a lot of variations so okay this line
has never been played so will will come
off it for a minute but I just wanted to
give you that example of what you can
possibly do if they take with their
night which at club level might be a
popular move because I've a lot of
people to chess club they took with
their night this week you know that's
what they decided to do in the database
you'll find hardly anybody has ever done
it but it's still something that's good
to know because okay at the club level
that's some of the people play okay but
instead let's look at the main move here
which is to take with the Queen now if
you play Bishop to d7
you'll transpose into the later part of
this lecture the main line and when
deciding back in this position after I
take here what to do whether you're just
going to take right away or if you're
going to check and then take this way
and triangulate one important thing is
the check move order if you play Queen
a4 check you're avoiding certain lines
that the black player can choose from so
in this position we can go away back
into the main line we have that option
Bishop d6 might also be possible
all but it is also interesting to look
at this line which is sort of an endgame
variation and it's kind of strange
because when you're down upon you don't
often think I want to just go right for
this end game and if you look at
different sources they have mixed
feelings about this position some people
think this is just fine for black some
people think well this is you shouldn't
play this way at all you should avoid it
so we'll have a look at it and we'll
give you guys a chance to decide for
yourselves okay so we're down upon but
already black has some very
uncomfortable threats and so already
white has to play very very accurately
you know if you let me go to one of
those squares and then I go to c2 and
fork your king and rook you can end up
in a lot of trouble and I think - I
really do want to challenge the class
just to give you an idea of how tough it
can be to play the white side of this
position if you guys were white how
would you handle this position there's
there's a lot of ways you can go wrong
here so and when you when you're white
and you know you accept again but you
kind of want to prove that I can take it
and hold on to the pawn that's that's
the whole point you have to set your
gambit is unsound I'll just take it hold
on to it and it is sort of a theoretical
class so we do at least in this class
care about trying to achieve a you know
theoretical advantage from the opening
some people like to play practically and
play stuff that you know doesn't give
you any advantage and then you try to
play that position that's another
approach to chess but we want to play
the the most precise move here and try
to prove an advantage as white right you
can't stop me from going to both squares
you can only stop me from going to one
choose wisely
calculating a three maybe a three what
are we gonna do you're gonna run your
king over here is that what you're gonna
do or I guess which square did you want
to go to I'll let you will you pick pick
your poison
dude yeah you really want to walk into
that yes this is actually after a three
already losing I mean okay you can't
walk into the pin because if you go in
the light square I can check you you
know if your King goes here and then you
like to drop it in also I could just
check and go here so yeah you can't do
that which leaves you kind of limited as
to your choices because I'm just working
you right and then I just for Q and that
wins for black so yeah you're already
losing and this can be a massive point
score at the club level because you know
a3 is just so natural but if you just
keep doing this it doesn't matter where
you go
I've already checked this so I just kind
of knew that this was the move you did
this and check and take the broken ah ah
okay yeah you know yet wait to go here
and this and then I take all your stuff
okay so yeah I mean if somebody's never
seen this before and they're thinking
why did you go into endgame I'm up upon
it's very easy to go wrong in a3
just already game over so that being
said the main move here is III and the
point is kind of funny now there's
different things that black can do and
you can do you know you can do do other
things but let's look at this very
entertaining variation so night to be
four okay obviously I'm jumping into c2
again but now we'll see the difference
with the move III
white now has well only one move you can
pause at home I'm going to give it away
for the live audience the only move
white has here Bishop b5 check and this
is sort of disruptive I don't want to
drop my knight back I don't want to go I
don't want to go and trade so I don't
want to move my pieces back so I'll have
a little bit of guts Oh King e7 and this
is the move and now White's best move
here is again funny so you may want to
pause and see if you can play White's
best move because again you know white
kind of has to know this or sometimes
it's hard to find a move like this but
the main move King f1 now you're not
going to fork me so look at this already
a very crazy variation both Kings have
moved to seemingly random positions and
you know so it's already sort of an
amazing position you don't see this
every day and will give you just a
little more insight into what might
possibly happen if this variation should
occur okay let's just develop our
Knights that makes sense and already
will see sort of some tactical
continuation here first I'll play Knight
to C - okay force you over I'm just
controlling e1 with my knight and now a
tactical move Knight to d4
and okay most people here have played
Bishop to e2 controlling you know some
of these squares especially d1 and play
might continue like like this you can
get you can see an example like this so
this might you might get a lot of
pressure here for your pawn so this is
probably fine for black yeah I assume
White's better because that's how chess
works no matter what why it's always a
little bit better in the opening but
okay this is playable for black so this
is sort of the position that you might
want to take a look at but what I think
is is rather humorous about this
position if we go back to this position
here is that white can fall for the trap
of taking this knight in allowing white
to drop his rook all the way back to d1
so even taking this is fine if I just
want to show this mostly because it's
amusing at least to me okay so we go
here take the rook Knight g3 and the
rook is trapped okay I take here and
your rook is trapped but you take me I
take you Bishop d3 and it looks like
white is simply playing king d 2 and
then capturing this piece now there's a
very very crafty plan for black very
crafty I'm going to play this move g6
well well understand now your best move
is probably to go here we'll look at
this will come we'll come right back
we'll look at King d2 so this is
probably our best move I take here you
take care and then also what's funny is
the computer wants you to just stay in
the center because that's what the
computer cares about you can also take
here but it's funny the computer move is
and just go to the center but I think
against the human I'd probably take the
pawn but ok so here and the computers
like equal equal equal alright good job
you equalize look black in a very
complicated variation
but I do want to point out this other
quite entertaining
situation and now there's one winning
move for black and it might really
surprise you so go ahead and pause your
video we'll give you guys a chance here
to see if you can be a superstar now I
already shaking your head yeah I can't
do it so it is amazing yeah yeah don't
give up you do it do you have to think
pretty deep into the position I guess
you want to move the King to get the
dark squared Bishop out okay I'm going
to just take your night though it
doesn't matter where you go I'm going to
take your night it's something like this
is better for white to pieces for a
Brooke wait better
so it's amazing someone give it away for
the live audience
the amazing winning move here Bishop h6
doesn't make any sense okay doesn't make
any sense why would this pin mean
anything well okay so if you take check
and you can move your king away and then
I take your bishop though surprisingly
you also can play this move that at
first just looks like a blunder but it
might be your best move here and now
some people a lot of people I showed
this to they can't find this move so
again you may want to pause your video
okay your rook is hanging so if you take
my bishop I take you're broke so again
we have to be sort of cunning okay so
the move here is just move your rook
backwards and if you take this I have
ripped you one and I get pieces back and
I'm up material so whichever piece you
say if I take the other one okay so we
can see there's some sort of really
imaginative solutions and a lot of these
positions so you do kind of need to be
sort of a creative player I mean just
look at this line you know even and okay
if you have never seen this as white in
the black King just confidently goes to
e7 you just slam it it's like oh I mean
what's going on how do I solve these
issues and he has to come up with the
move King f1 but we go back so that's
the endgame variation that you can
choose to go into or not obviously again
if in this position you desire you can
transpose to what we're about to see
with the move Bishop to d7 okay
yes definitely yes so the question is
why does this work is it just because
your head in development and certainly
it is and you already have a threat so
it's going to be black that has threats
really early on it's move eight and
already you know our night is going to
one of these places and you have to be
able to figure this out as white and
play very accurately so okay this again
it can be a big point score in your your
tournaments if people just mess up
immediately so here we go okay they take
on d4 and we'll look at what most
consider the more accurate line although
if white wants to go into the endgame
variation he can play that other way um
so now okay I have to put my bishop in
the way so now when you take my pawn I
don't have knight c6 getting a tempo and
okay probably ninety six is a better
move for me than Bishop to d7 so okay I
take here white takes back again we're
down upon so I'm thinking maybe maybe
for tomorrow's lecture yeah we could do
it now maybe we'll do it now yeah okay
the main move here you're on our beep on
nice e6 but a rare move and it kind of
keeps with the theme of the opening I
don't think it's a particularly good
move but refuting it can be hard is this
move Knight to f6 offering the beep on
which most humans don't take but is
probably the critical line I don't know
why people don't take it and this would
transpose to what we're going to see if
after this we play Knight to c6 then
we're going to get the main line again
it will undo this today or tomorrow
maybe tomorrow go go prepare this and
I'll play either side you want tomorrow
yeah tonight we're just going to focus
here we're gonna try to get closer to
the main line so Knight to c6 ok
shielding RB pawn Knight f6 comes next
we develop with tempo
and hopefully we can get our pieces out
a lot faster than our opponents and and
crush them immediately now the most
popular move here and come on in is
perhaps the most natural move Knight f3
just develop your your piece III is
likely to transpose if that's what white
decides to play in this position but I
do want to show one game with the move
Bishop to g5 and this is a sort of
famous game
baaji up here versus Alexander le eken
it was played in 1931 so we will check
out this game and ok again we see that
this Bishop to g5 move usually is not to
be recommended for white sometimes
imagine that that White Queen is out of
the way
sometimes it's because we put our Bishop
here and then our Queen here and we
attack two things so that sometimes is
the reason and sometimes as we'll see if
there's ever a night here and you take
it and I take back we saw kind of in
that other variation that this is really
important to protect that beep on so in
general that's not the way white should
set up
you should play Knight f3 III and then
go Castle but okay how can this seems
pretty good so Knight d6 was played and
the Queen went back to D to h6 do you
want to give me your Bishop and so sort
of a controversial decision already
white parts with his bishop okay we take
back and white says simply I'm up upon
we traded a piece but this can actually
be quite dangerous and white goes wrong
immediately in this game so I have two
bishops I might even think of castling
queenside lining my row cup with your
queen that could help me gain more time
and in the game after e3 yeah a castle
and we'll see in lots of lines there's
always a rook lined up with McQueen and
then sometimes we were threatening
discoveries and in this game remarkably
White Castle the Queen side and already
the game is over so
shockingly white is already losing so I
do go I want to give you guys a chance
can you play like a world champion can
you play like an ally akin in this
position so go ahead pause your videos
and and then the little kid will figure
it out while everybody else is
scratching their head do you have a good
discovered attack yeah yeah so it looks
like yes it looks like yeah if you just
move then okay what a blunder I just
take this and you're right you're gonna
take it with a rook there's a knight
yeah okay so even that might be good for
black though you can do even better so
white okay he saw that he's you know
even if you just see this then okay
alright I've already won some material
and you're still exposed and my pieces
are pretty good but white had an idea in
mind his idea was okay when you attack
my rook I play Knight d5 okay so it's
getting complicated it's I mean it's
already a very complicated position and
that's what you're going to get when you
play this opening when you play this
opening you're going to get a
complicated messy position so it's good
for beating lower rated players it's
good for surprising higher rated players
okay and it's also interesting too if
you just the fun Shara Henning gambit as
a whole if you check different sources
some will say it's refuted it's super
dubious some will say no it's quite
valid it's you know there's no
reputation so when there's a line like
that and people are sort of undecided
maybe it's maybe it's unplayable maybe
it's not that means at the club level
it's definitely playable Andrew Queen d6
okay I guess I'll not let you take my
rook I guess maybe Knight f3 too but
you yeah you can do better
just just take the rook then you're
taking the Queen
mm-hmm yes you can save your bishop and
I saved my night somewhere I don't know
why it's probably better but it is kind
of it's probably easy to play black but
I don't know I assume white is better
here because it's I'm off upon yeah so
yeah if you don't do something brilliant
then I'm up upon so if we trade lots of
stuff and I don't get checkmated and you
don't win any material then yay I did it
so the amazing move played in this
position and again you can pause if you
need a little bit more time it takes d5
just just give me it
okay now for another amazing move and
this is sort of the kind of move it's
it's a theme we've seen a little bit but
it's going to be on the other side of
the board so black later another really
surprising and powerful move in this
position and this is the the true gem of
the whole game this is what makes this
game so famous and so amazing is this
next move that okay presumably the
opponent did not see this move because
this man it's a good move
once you see it Bishop a3 excellent yeah
so I'm threatening mate that's that's
good I'm gonna play route d8 I'm gonna
take your rook I got all sorts of stuff
so he was not tempted to take in the
game which very smart now it's over
check if you go here I'm gonna take all
your stuff okay so if you go here now I
can take this check you take this all
right let me take all your stuff let me
take all your stuff let me go here and
you're up a piece but I know how to use
my pieces better than you so I'm going
to come in I'm gonna use my pieces and I
should be able to to win this game here
is black I mean okay
all right so going back to this position
so he didn't take which is okay very
smart all right Queen b3 I didn't get
checkmated yeah so we took the rook yeah
he took
now instead of moving the bishop which
obviously is tempting took on f2 you
take my bishop I take your Bishop with
check all right so you defended all
right you're taking my bishop you'll get
my bishop out and we'll go a little bit
quickly through this game check I do not
want to trach Wiens with you because I
want to checkmate you but here again
we'll pause because okay another really
powerful move was played here by black
so I do want to give you guys a time to
look at this this position as well not
to tell me what time it is because I
don't I don't have any idea you made me
turn myself on off so the aliens don't
hear me
so what yeah what time is it seven
eleven
all right
so probably do it in two parts because
there's one more
you want to check on B 494 check okay
I have Drive one move okay I found it
assume you're better but what what's
your move now me am I supposed to be
scared
five oh I mean ah what's funny yeah it
works I think here I'm gonna do to you
what you did to me you ready for this I
hope it works cuz I'm gonna do it to you
right
ha ha ah ha right back at ya
alright I threatened mate in your queen
hey now don't do something I didn't see
because I'm a genius
if you don't refute me take what let's
take what the night okay go me until the
Internet puts it on the computer and
repeats me okay
so again instead and also it should be
pointed out white does have a mini
threat an escape in this position he
wants to go here check and then force
the Queen trade so and then blacks still
a lot better but if you don't check make
me I survive and black really wanted to
check me to his opponent okay so he
played rook c8 bringing my rook into the
game discoveries and white did end up
checking
the crazy 95 move was played yeah it is
awesome thanks okay through a check-in
and okay after he protected his rook and
threatened rook a five and bringing the
Queen yeah you're white already gave it
up so I said no again it's a powerful
display of the initiative over material
and again here's your extra material but
you didn't use it so that's what black
is playing for he's trying to get an
early attack or try to create problems
as early as possible and sometimes it's
you know right after the opening is
started there's already problems that
you need to solve and that's difficult
over the board so this is an excellent
weapon that I would recommend to a lot
of people give a serious look at okay
we're going to return here to the
initial position and we take on d4
alright now we want to look at the main
line after Queen to a4 actually I also
do want to mention this movable final b5
you didn't see that move coming so okay
and this move was played in 2006 in the
US Championship was a game between
kamila bag and Skye T and Hikaru
Nakamura
so Hikaru did lose this game is black
but if and I guess this move is pretty
pretty dubious I mean don't you don't
want to play this way but I do want to
again assuming we have time show you
guys that it can be very difficult when
surprised like this to actually find the
right continuation and I think if white
finds the next series of 20 moves he's
probably better and I guess if Cara was
like alright I'll risk it and in the
game you know it was sort of even
forever and ever
white didn't truly punish it I mean it
was there's a good game we can go look
it up but you know he's risking all
right I might be worse against the lower
rated opponent and then hopefully I can
outplay her from my position but what
you guys do here I mean this already is
it's complicated I like to just see what
you
as would do just so that you can put
yourself in the mind of the white player
when totally surprised is little b5 ah
doesn't understand the point what do you
want to take take on d4 okay
this certainly makes a lot of sense okay
now again I exploit the pin alright you
can go back now I take here and here's
where you can mess up yeah we'll give
you the chance to mess up you can do it
I'll take on d5 with the Queen
the main move there actually was a thief
or just so this is that's the move so
but let's look at this because this is
what I think a lot of people would play
it's not so important I just wanted to
hopefully get the initiative here
otherwise not to cut so much of this out
when they outplay me and beat me then
it'll look bad on the internet
especially if Aaron now plays me from
this position okay
yep that's the move uh-huh I think it's
here or is it - I mean I have six first
nine eight six I think it's here and
then yeah I think it's something like
this let's see if we can remember the
line and I go here this is lime so
there's stuff like this and okay I don't
think that this should really work out
for you even if you take this way so all
right I'm not trying to say b5 is a good
move or you should play it or anything
yeah so this is probably the simplest
way to get an advantage so I do like the
way you guys play it after that in the
game she went here which is a bit more
theoretical so it's also should be fine
and you're threatening some double
checks so you have to play here and now
this move d6 so it forces us really to
take the knight I can't let you fork me
and I block and okay in the game there
was a very interesting position we're
not going to go much farther than this
but again you can see that this is sort
of the way that black you know chose to
set up and it was probably already equal
here so maybe there was some play that
could have been better along the way but
I just want to point out this
possibility you can go explore it on
your own if you want there's the super
crazy radical b5 it's no good but you
know you startled them you didn't see
that coming
yeah so it's right after you check b5
all right but will will play the normal
move yeah actually I think actually I'm
like we're going to jump to the other
games or but this is the game between
Irina crush and Spyro Don cab missus
will say that's it we can't see their
names so we'll say that that's their
names Spence I'm a lil no and we'll get
to this let's just check out this game
real quick all right so check we're
looking at this variation let's play the
normal way we'll take knight c6 and
we're going to look at the main move
here Knight f3 so this is the main move
and weights playing a simple i'll op
upon i developed by castle okay i get
this free move so when you go back ship
c5 alright taking aim at f2 may be very
active post for my bishop what typically
blunts them out now this move queen a
seven so I'm I'm not I'm not telling you
which way I'm going to castle and very
often you do want to Castle queenside
bring your rook to the D file obviously
your Queen side is a little bit loose is
black so it can easily backfire but
we're playing for the quick initiative
we got to make use of it right now right
here right now we're going to use the
initiative and as soon as you play here
I'm going to castle and I'm already
threatening Bishop to h3 so yeah I mean
silly move Bishop h3 I'm on your queen
and your G phone so you do have to be
careful so white normally defends is
jeep on like a slow and so here we get
the start of the main line and now we're
going to see both sides
I mean it's opposite side castling
attack each other so already another
exciting move g5 here I come
you want to take it if we had more time
we could look at it and white maybe
doesn't lose if you
maybe he doesn't lose that's close the
one problem we'll look at it is if here
and you just drop back which yeah I got
it and I run away you're already in
trouble
so you know you can do this and this
we're already in trouble
and then all my nights jump in here you
don't like it also I take your queen
okay yes I threaten your queen and your
pawn
I think you have to play g3 and then who
know I take something take your point I
guess but there is this move
we'll go over it I don't care how
impatient Bensimon is there's this movie
for and we'll just show the super
monster crazy computer line here and
then why place this confusing move we
take and we go here and run the bishop
but now he plays here you can't really
move the knight still and white is
threatening to go here like if here
which is the obvious move here and then
you know if you move I'm taking this and
if you take back I embarrass you
so the computer wants you to just take
this what's the big deal and then this
crazy crazy line hey black spinner so
white maybe doesn't lose if you take
that G pawn but it's very very scary
hopefully you can avoid the temptation
and among the other moves that white can
play the sharpest and most exciting and
perhaps the best is to fight fire with
fire be for doing the same exact thing
and probably black is just best advised
to accept this gambit
and white is hoping I get to use the B
file my queen comes in my Knights jump
in
you know all this stuff happens to you
and I go like this with white and then I
went that's what white is hoping for so
after the move be for black is it's
probably best to just accept this gambit
and now let's let's see if I can get
enough pressure here Bishop b2 is the
main move but in the game night to b5
which also is a common idea
she'll put her Bishop on b2 in just a
second or I guess he will put his Bishop
on b2 so I just hoping I get some
pressure here and the night is coming in
that's it's quite sharp it's quite
dangerous for both sides move h5 was
played and white went through with the
plan we mentioned and just brought the
Queen in so this is why you play this
too it's very sharp it's very
double-edged both sides are going to
attack each other but in this position
you can play the move a six and so
basically you're forced to take on c6
because if you just drop back for
example we take here I'm on your queen
and I'm on all your stuff so basically
you have to take but now what are you
going to do your Knights end up in well
he took on f6
and this is whoa I guess the last time
we'll ask the audience what they would
play in this position so again you can
pause at home it's not taking nf6 you're
guessing good guess
because otherwise why did I ask you
because here and this is probably good
for white because my attack is still
going on so instead a nice move was
played after you took my knight simply
we need for threatening me so I decided
not to get mated that was good so white
parted with the pawn and in this game
some mistakes were made but it's still
quite a quite a nice game black took
here which probably isn't right I think
it's here this is the move you should
play Bishop c5 I don't know
but after here boy took this black one
here which is actually a mistake but for
time let's get through this game another
check
and now the the winning move is here but
let's focus on what happens black took
here a counter blunder so now again it's
black to play and black has a very
strong move so white must have
overlooked the power of this next move
if you can find this next move you win
so I guess I will ask you guess one more
question
what would you guys play in this
position when is the winning move black
rook hg8 awesome move awesome move yeah
the point is yes you can't play here due
to this
so there's sorry after this move there's
just nothing that can be done remarkably
this what was tried in the game but now
another strong move just rook d3
attacking f3 again that's strong enough
and you're going you're going to like to
finish all right it takes here white
gets desperate check and taking um b7 ok
this is desperation but you know I'm
trying and now after this move a very
similar move to the alien game in that
it's a discovered move that just wins
so here rook b3 game over it's it's
mating 3 so you can give some of your
pieces away and then get made it so I
hope that gives you guys a good
indication of just how sharp and
aggressive this opening can be and for
those that really like to fight for the
initiative especially with black early
on you want to play some fighting chests
you want to get you know the battle
going right away and you want to prove
that yeah you could take your pawn but
I'll get all my pieces out and I'll
cause threats for you very very early on
in the game this might be the opening
for you hopefully that helped in I'll
see you guys next week